by round of applause how many people in
here remember tan M M's
that is not everybody
some of y'all have been living among us
in a tanless Eminem World
I'll tell you what the [__] happened to
tan Eminem's
1995.
Mars candy decides that two Browns are
redundant
they kill off the tans
said they opened a vote to all of us
said we voted blue I didn't vote for
[__]
they killed tan M M's and that is what
happened I looked it up for this joke
I wanted to be funny and factual
the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
foreign
[Applause]
Studios you know I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler on all your
social media I want to say thank you
guys right now
um the special is doing really well I
can't believe the support
um the the Channel's growing so thank
you guys if you haven't watched my
special Lefty son go check it out uh
almost died and still brought it to
y'all still in the hospital making notes
and [__] while they're telling me I got
clots and stuff in my lungs so yeah that
happened and boom boom boom boom there's
a free special out on YouTube right now
all right uh make sure you're subscribed
share it like it all that good stuff if
you gotta have more then I'm telling you
every week you gotta check out the
patreon it's called the Honeydew with
y'all and I highlight the low lights
with you all and you all have the
wildest [__] stories that are out
there we've talked to people who've died
we've talked to someone who had two
[__] we talked to a lady who had I
think it was four [__] uh we talked
to a guy that had a double lung
transplant we're out there talking to
salt one one guy solved the Cold Case 18
year old Cold Case go check it out it's
five bucks a month that's it there's no
tears no levels nothing sign up for a
year you're getting over a month free
and if you're looking for another
podcast and check out an old one called
The Crab Feast it's the one I used to do
with Jay Larson and it's got all the
same fans and uh guests I mean on the
podcast you know and love today
everybody's there and it's Audio Only so
check it out you can listen to it also
come see me on tour I'm just getting
back out there now end of May May 26th
and 27th I'll be in Fort Wayne Indiana
June 23rd and 24th Tacoma Washington and
July 7th and 8th Appleton Wisconsin
unfortunately Tulsa uh the club will not
be open in time so they're telling me we
need to reschedule so the dates for the
21st and 22nd will be rescheduled all
right that's the biz thank you for being
patient you guys know we're doing over
here we highlight the low lights I
always say that these are the stories
behind the storytellers and today I'm
very excited to have this guest here
first time on the Honeydew ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Chris gethard
welcome to the Honeydew Chris thank you
so much for having me now you said four
[__] four four [__] for it I'm
good if that doesn't give people to sign
up for the patreon that doesn't at least
you at least drop your five bucks to
listen to that and then cancel it it's
like it's like a buck 25 an [__] you
know what I mean it's a good deal it's a
real deal you buy in bulk it's the
Costco system Costco for [__]
well it's a pleasure to have you here oh
it's a joy thanks for having me I've
known about you for a while because uh I
really did enjoy your show that you used
to have on uh was it true true TV and
then Public Access for many years before
that
um but now you've got a lot going on of
course as always I just met you in New
York for the first time yeah and uh I'm
glad to have you here so before we get
into whatever we're going to talk about
please plug and promote everything sure
uh Chris geth.com that's where all my
tour dates go I know I'm keeping it slow
this summer I just I just taped the
special so I'm slowing down but
Toronto's coming up I know that and then
Chris Geth on Instagram and Chris
gethard on Twitter and I've got the
beautiful Anonymous podcast which I
think is a kindred spirit to this show
in a lot of ways because we just take
phone calls from random people and they
just talk for an hour and I can't hang
up and it gets very intense and I have a
feeling there's some crossover for sure
and is it one guest each time or do you
have one guest they don't tell me their
name I I can't hang up some of them are
super funny and then some of them are
like
you know I lost a kid or I found out my
husband was a into Kitty porn you know
like you get the one calls like that and
then you get the calls from like this
last week guy was like I'm really into
yo-yos can I just tell you like why I
think yo-yos are cool and like who the
best yo-yoers are in the yo-yo scene and
I was like yeah so we get both we get
the light ones we get the funny ones the
weird ones the dark ones and uh yeah
beautiful Anonymous and I also have a
much smaller labor of love called New
Jersey is the world about my my home
state and my love for it so you're from
New Jersey yeah I I it's funny I feel
like Jersey has a pride that uh I feel
Maryland's where I'm from carries the
same sort of Pride like I think so I
think so but I mean Jersey my neighbor
Jen is a big Jersey Girl drives her Jeep
and it's all Jersey Girl Jersey yeah so
what where did you grow up and what was
it like grew up in a town called West
Orange uh it's a suburb of Newark New
Jersey
I think
you know kind of overshadowed by New
York I think Marilyn probably has some
of that right like Baltimore is known
for like you know everybody thinks of it
as one thing and it's a little
overshadowed by DC and then the suburbs
yeah exactly it's just the stop in
between those two there you go like
Jersey has that similar thing and West
Orange was a great town to grow up it
was a very
diverse Town even when I was growing up
there in the 80s and 90s
um you know racially economically and
there's a lot of beautiful things about
it was if you know if we're talking low
lights
I will say I also grew up in a way where
there was a lot of uh a lot of my
friends when I see them we do still talk
about that it also was a town that was
just unnecessarily obsessed with
toughness
and uh
I mean I have family in Trenton and I
still remember the sign Trenton makes
the world takes and that's the Jersey
attitude right there we make stuff
everybody else not we're giving it to
you or selling it makes the world such a
specific word and it's on the side of a
bridge and it's sort of like like half
dead industrial
the whole thing so yeah there was a lot
of uh
definitely
bullying definitely saw some things
growing up that made me not trust people
definitely had a
very arms length relationship with
authority and teachers because there was
a lot of
a lot of a lot of just growing up
especially I have a brother he's two and
a half years older than me and he really
took it hard from the bullies is it just
the two of you yeah so then I grew up
and was kind of like
all right I gotta learn how to fight and
I was Tiny and not really a Fighter's
personality and where are you uh
interacting with these people in school
sports school all of it yeah yeah and
and also
um
grew up in a neighborhood where almost
every family including mine was Irish
Catholic
um there's a lot of Irish Catholic kids
and there's a Catholic school too we
used to hang out in the parking lot at
that school I went to public school
uh but those kids were some of those
kids still
a couple I was some of my earliest
acting gigs was I used to do bits on
Conan O'Brien's show like I'm talking 20
years ago 25 years ago at this point
when he had the late night you know the
Seth Meyer slot now
and I I someone told me they were in a
bar in my hometown
and uh they had the TVs running after
there must have been some game on NBC
and all of a sudden I pop up and this
dude's like why everybody quiet down
that kid's from my neighborhood show
some respect turn the volume up
and my friend who related this story to
me goes
he's telling me I go who was it and he
tells me the name I was like that's
crazy because if that guy was crossing
the street in front of me I'd hit the
gas not the brakes
I fantasize about that motherfucker's
death and he's the one showing Hometown
Pride all right
so just grew up in a way where I just
really learned not to trust were your
parents together parents were together
and my household was pretty great okay
um
my parents both grew up in the
neighborhood how old are you I'm about
to turn 43. okay for 1980. what's your
what's your parents mentality to this
bullying is it a Sticks and Stones sort
of thing or are they like you need to
defend yourself like where are they at
then you need to defend yourself okay
I remember distinctly one of one of my
formative childhood memories was my dad
once my brother once was dealing with
some bully my dad came home
and he was like well then
you know if they hit you you hit them
harder if you see him coming you get the
first shot and then he goes
if you have to you pick up a rock you
bash in their skull if you have to
subscribe and my brother with my brother
to his credit was like dad chill you
know like my brother was like an artsy
weird kid who was like I don't think
that's me I on the other hand was like
yeah Rock got it
and to this day I'm still unwrapping
something I mean my dad I got multiple
stories about my dad tracking down some
of these kids real and telling them you
know going to their parents or the kids
one bully in particular who uh yeah tell
me he went to their parents first
because it was it was it because look
it's also I feel some sympathy for these
kids because there was also houses in my
neighborhood where it's like
you knew okay that those kids are
they never go home and you start to
learn okay their parents are drinkers or
their parents hit them yeah and you
learn oh that's why they're out all
night right they don't want to go home
it's not safe at home but now they're
out getting in touch and they're
taking out that anger on
the smaller kids and the kids whose last
names spell the words get hard you're
done with the kids with glasses like
it was what it was
um
some there's one kid in particular I
remember my dad went to his father a
couple times and was like the [__]
needs to stop and the dad was like I try
to talk to him and this and then kept
getting worse and worse and
one day my dad found him hanging out in
a parking lot how old was the kid at the
time he's 17 at the time recorded the
story because my dad goes you're 17 and
he's like so what my dad goes okay well
if I wait a year I'll get in a lot less
trouble
kid just stared at him and my dad goes
you know
long story short my dad basically said
to him
someday I have this bad feeling I'm
gonna be driving home and there's gonna
be an accident
and if there is I just have this
terrible feeling that if I ever hit you
with a car it's gonna I'm gonna hit you
so [__] hard it takes them weeks to
find your body in the woods he told that
to like a teenager
like threatened you know my dad my my
dad's a great guy my dad's a great guy
never laid a hand on me but like also I
it's funny I've been telling some of
these stories on stage and I've had a
couple of buddies who I'm still tight
with from growing up
come and seen that and I told I tell
that story I just taped the special for
audible that'll come out later this year
and that story is in it a longer version
of it and I had a buddy my friend
Bonaduce
he co-hosted that New Jersey podcast but
he was like dude I never forgot the
first time I met your dad he because
this kid grew up in the other side of
town so he was in high school he was
actually my brother's friend
first and he came over and he's like
your dad was sitting in his armchair and
he was like your Nick right he's like
yes sir he's like I've heard about you
which is already an ominous thing to say
you know when he said he's like your dad
got up
gave me a handshake that was like a man
handshake like I was a kid and he made
sure he gave me the man handshake and he
was like the second your dad shook my
hand he's like I always remember
thinking like this guy seems like a good
man and I never ever want him mad at me
that was his initial impression I mean
my dad had a story from when I was a
baby my mom tells this one of um
we lived in a part of town that was
just you know for a Suburban town that
is generally a good town it was the
sketchiest pocket
and uh there's some he had just bought
his first house and there were some kids
they were vandalizing the house they
kept kicking in the aluminum door my dad
put up this brand new door and these
kids kicked it in and hammered out he's
like
you know my dad didn't have any money
he's like you know it represents so much
this door he put on his house
and he started sleeping on the porch at
night he under a pile of blankets
and it for like because they did it more
than one night it happened two or three
times he's like [__] this
and my mom eventually sleeping out there
a couple nights my mom's like this is
crazy like you're sleeping on the poor
he's like you're right so if he finally
he goes back to bed that night they
should kick it and he's like [__] this
so he goes back out into this nest of
blankets that he's built
and next night he hears him coming
he wakes up he's like oh [__] I think
it's them and they boom they kick in the
door he comes flying and my dad is uh
six two 220. I I I look like my mom's
side of the family he's bigger and he
chased these kids into a park and and um
there was a chain across the parking lot
to keep cars out at night he didn't know
that and he hit it and he went face down
in all this mud so he's like this huge
guy
and he cornered them in the park um up
this wall and uh a few of them he
managed to get them where they he was in
front of them and there's no place for
them to go
and uh like I said a lot of the families
in this neighborhood two three
generations my parents met at the
Catholic school a lot of the you know
you start to realize everybody's parents
have crossed paths Larry Johnson's kids
exactly a lot of that yeah so my dad's
like which one you kick the door which
one do you kick the door and nobody's
answering them like nobody wants to rat
and my dad points at one kid and he's
like well I know which family you're
from and he drops the kid's last name
he's like I know I know you folks your
dad's about Dennis it's like that type
of thing you know like your dad probably
towed my car at some point or something
and he's like so if you don't want to
tell me I know which one you are so I
can track you down and he goes you
either tell me which one did kick my
door or I'm assuming you did it and I'm
coming back here with a pipe and I'm
bashing in your [__] head my dad said
that to a kid you know and uh at that
point the cops showed up yeah and my dad
of course my dad is also like
he put himself through school in three
years he eventually went and got a PhD
later in life he's a smart reasonable
guy
I'm a little older than 50. yeah I'm
seven years older than you we're a weird
pocket of men in time right now our dads
and grandfathers fought in World Wars
and Vietnam and things Korea and and
we're like I want to make people laugh
you know or I want to dance
[__] are you talking about I have a
four-year-old son now too and I'm
sitting here going like
I don't want him to I don't want him to
be like I remember seeing kids where
it's like
kid who is like a sports star in my town
and he missed a foul shot at the end of
a game and as we all left we saw his dad
had him cornered and was like lacing it
how could you miss that [__] shot you
embarrassed me I'm like
I can't even imagine Dad's right now I
think most of us I'm sure that still
happens but by and large
you'd see that today you go whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa we want to raise
ourselves you'd intervene you'd step in
yeah like at the very least you'd be
like step away and take it come on dude
so it's like then you're like what the
[__] did you do but like you said our
dads were like Vietnam World War II yeah
and we're trying to raise Sons but it's
like how do we become this new type of
Dad when the we're the ones who the
example was set very different we're the
hinge yeah so anyway the cops showed up
in this park
and my dad immediately just turns around
and of course it's like oh officers so
good to see you like it was and the cops
are like we're not worried about the
kids we're covering we're worried about
the mud covered lunatic ranting about
hitting people with pipes and then um
but the cops knew these kids they they
this park historically in my town
Colgate Park in West Orange was like
that delinquents hung out there so they
quickly realized what was happening and
my dad got home he found out my mom
called the cops on him no yeah cause my
brother was two and a half I was a
newborn my mom's like he's gonna kill a
kid and go to jail like he's gonna kill
a kid so there was some chaos in the
neighborhood and like I said though I'm
also completely obsessed with where I
grew up and represented to this day
but there was a lot of that and I
remember like as far as the bullying
goes too like stuff like um
we started here and there were kids so
we lived right on the border West Orange
and orange and orange is a tougher town
we started here in middle school there's
some kids from Orange coming up and
they're like jumping people and taking
stuff
so my buddy and his older brother one
day they go to walk home from school
and there's these kids standing just on
the other side of the fence by these
Billboards on Main Street in our town
my buddies and his brother are like oh
[__] it's those kids from Orange
they go back to the school
and they're like so there's these rumors
that people keep getting jumped and
we're pretty sure the kids doing it are
right there and I'm like oh where are
they
I think oh they're out in front of the
Billboards
and the people they talk to in the
office just go oh well that's not on
school property
and they're like it's on the other side
of a chain link like we can see them
from the front steps it's right there
and they're like it's not school
property it's not it's not our problem
and my friends are like so what do we do
and they're like it's not school and
then my friends
step off school property
kids beat the [__] out of them take
their Walkman
and go back to Orange
and that's the type of thing that I just
saw too much of
my like stuff like that where it was
just like I don't trust anybody and I
don't trust adults
and that was and what age is that star
for you elementary school or middle
school a lot of it started like
Elementary School and also having my
brother's three grades ahead of me
and I remember him coming home and
dealing with it so even as I was
entering school I was vaguely aware of
like okay bad things can happen at
school and then especially when he hit
Junior High
it was always like I I always feel so
awful because my brother
he would walk in with it untested but
and then I'd be aware of how to navigate
it a little better
so it was kind of like by the time I was
in like
fourth fifth grade
I was seeing what was happening to him
in the junior high and I was like I'm
gonna have to [__] go there she's the
Marines and you're the Navy he's the
canary he's going he's the canary who
gets sent into the coal mine but also I
go back to thinking about your father
too this is his name
this is he he's certainly has heard this
kind of [__] growing up so it makes
sense to me that he's like listen you
little [__] like I'm sure it's
a trigger for him there's no way you
have the last name that's spelled get
hard and you don't have guys from the
60s did you want to get it even better
his first name is Ken he's Kenneth his
name is Ken gethard no swear to God
his older brother my Uncle Bill will get
hard my grandfather was less let's get
hurt no I don't know why
I'm see Paul get hard my brother my
brother is Greg Ken gethard like we just
keep picking names
it's like why do we keep making worse so
dude you'll love this because you're
liking these stories about my dad
so dude when I
I had a point in like I feel so bad
because it was like my mid-20s all of a
sudden I started to realize I could talk
to my dad
okay yeah and I feel awful because
he re at one point he and I were talking
about that
and I was like
because he used to ask me to help him
move whenever they moved and I was like
that's when I felt like you and I
finally could like let our guards down
about he's like you're like 27 28 when
we and I was like he's like you couldn't
let your guard down around me so I was
like
yeah man like if I'm being honest yeah
like I just you were a hard-working guy
I never wanted to piss you off you're a
great dad like I told the kids skulls
you were an enforcer too you know yeah
and uh I said to him once once I was in
that stretch in my late 20s I go to I
was like
you know we took some [__] for the get
hard thing like did anybody did people
ever [__] with you with the Ken get hard
thing and he gave me the ultimate my dad
answer he goes yeah it happened once
hey boy
you get your ass whooped and I grew up
in the same neighbor you know what I
mean I grew up in the same neighborhood
yeah and all the kids [__] with us
were the kids of the kids people he grew
up with right but it should have been
like hey there was a little more group
of families where he knew who they were
they all went to the they were like five
or six Catholic schools in Essex County
New Jersey everybody went and knew who
my mom went to the valley my dad went to
Essex Catholic Oh that person went to
East Orange Catholic that person went
here that everybody knew each other's
families and histories and all your
grandparents were Irish Catholics
Church same church on Sunday the same
every the Irish American Club blah blah
blah my dad knew these kids and I'm like
man
that's an amazing answer it happened
once and then he told me
he said because my dad's a gentle guy
and he was always shy he was like a
bigger shy he's kind of shy nerdy guy
growing up but bigger
and he said it happened once and he
set an example and it never happened
again and I was like God damn what's the
worst
um bullying you ever had
for me personally
did people ever put hands on you oh
regularly regularly in school and [__]
too
when I tell you
that sixth seventh eighth grade
if you ask anybody I went to Junior High
School with they will verify my my tech
my town has a section called up the hill
and down the hill and it's exactly what
you assume yep up the hill it's a lot
nicer yeah so the high school had some
rough edges but the middle school [__]
flows downhill exactly the way it works
so the junior high school was rougher
because that was the split the junior
high was all the downhill little kids
concentrated in one place the high
school had kind of diluted a little bit
and you could find some friends from
some more stable areas of town you know
you could spread out a little bit when I
tell you
that there was a physical fight in my
junior high school almost every single
day for you I'm no not for me but in
general sure you were you were gonna at
least see a fight every day
it was more often than not true
um
and and for me I remember probably I
mean I saw saw a lot of bad stuff for me
probably the worst I remember once
kid wants in my gym class picked me up
and threw me across the gym what yeah
and I landed in a they had had the
badminton net set up and I landed on a
bunch of badminton equipment and I
picked up a racket and hit him so hard
that the thing broke [__] you where'd
you get him uh I think across like his
shoulder and chest
and then it got broken up and I remember
my dad picking me up
and he walked in and he was so pissed
and then we were driving home
I realized he wasn't necessarily pissed
that I stood up for myself
because me and the other kid would both
sit in the office he's like that kid was
a [__] foot taller than you he's like
are you crazy I'm like
what I gotta let them know at least that
you know at least it's gonna stop but I
remember once uh
for me and like I said
my brother took it worse but I uh I
remember once being in the parking lot
of uh Our Lady of Lourdes church and
this one kid was there and just walked
up to me and he was probably at five six
years older than me this Puerto Rican
kid in our neighborhood and he didn't
say a word to me and he just walked up
and I saw that all the other guys from
his crew like all the other kids his age
were watching and I was like
he walked up six years older than me
punched me in the face damn not a word
we'd never had a problem he just decided
and I got up and he was laughing and I
tried to swing back and he just hit me
again a couple times
and uh
I got out of there but I mean like that
like unprovoked just like hey guys watch
this pow like that was happening I up to
to put it in perspective
I got a Instagram DM
maybe 18 months ago okay so I was in my
40s yeah this is I would say that's
reason yeah considering is this dude he
goes hey man I grew up in your
neighborhood
uh
I don't know if you remember me and I
did he grew up down near Colgate Park
but he is a really good kid I remember
him he was like a little rough around
the edges but fundamentally a good kid I
remember like as soon as I saw his name
I was like I remember this dude
and he's like I wanted to thank you
because you became a comedian
and he's like it it's made it really
easy to keep tabs on you and because I'm
able to follow you he's like I was just
really psyched I looked you up and I was
just psyched to see you and your brother
are both still alive
dude I got a DM in my 40s and he
straight up was like dude great job
being alive still great job breathing
still and I've had a couple of them I've
had a couple couple people who uh I've
run into them you know people you lose
touch with people from your neighborhood
and then you wind up crossing paths and
I've had a couple people who have said
to me like
you know the stuff that went down with
with you guys was unforgivable and like
I'm sorry I didn't step in more you know
and dude the one guy the guy who I
referenced to um
who I said
if I if he crossed the street in front
of me I'd probably hit the gas
I finally a couple years ago I was
writing a lot about this stuff and like
I said I put a couple of these stories
in in uh
an hour that's coming out later this
year
and I messaged the guy and at first I
was kind of like this is the same guy
you would run over the dude who I had
have said out loud I would run him over
with a car and I'm like sitting here and
I'm like nervous like should I mess this
just I'm like I'm in my 40s
this guy was an [__] and I'm feeling
this childhood fear you know so I just
messaged him and I was like Hey dude I
was like
I'm not hung up on this
I'm not sitting around mad at you
I was like
I think you've heard I'm a comedian now
and I'm I'm working on some bits about
my childhood and I was like and I'm not
gonna name your name
but I was just kind of wondering like it
might help me
get some perspective on how to write
these bits I was like why did you bully
with all the smaller like why'd you
bully all the smaller kids so much you
[__] with us so much why'd you do it
and he was like because when I was
little the bigger kids [__] with me
bro it's the way of the neighborhood
hope you're well dude good job on
everything I was like
he doesn't even
like it doesn't they still these kids
don't blink and some of these kids were
like
targeting us I have her memories again
punched in the [__] face by these
people for no reason
I wasn't even talking wasn't even
talking [__]
just sometimes it happened you know like
dude I actually just had a you want to
talk about the worst it ever got for me
I remember one time that gang with that
kid and that Puerto Rican kid a few of
the other Irish Catholic kids
we were once at this park in our
neighborhood and they surrounded me and
my brother
and made us fight each other for their
Amusement get the [__] out like that's
dark right that is really dark yeah and
I remember we were like no stop because
me and my brother we were Irish Catholic
Brothers like it wasn't hard we would
fight all the time right of course
be like my turn for the Game Boy like no
it's not [__] pow my brother
punches me you know like that wasn't we
were brothers Irish Catholic Brothers we
fit that cliche closest person in the
world to me and also we would battle and
they would think it was funny and
they're like you guys fight come on
fight and we're like no stop this is
gross and I remember they started they
picked us up we were so much smaller
picked us up started swinging our legs
into each other like smashing our bodies
into each other to try to get us mad
enough and worked up enough to fight and
we did to get out of there we were like
we have to fight to get out of a circle
of bigger kids forcing us to have like a
[__] kumate for their Amusement this
is [__] up that is [__] up it's
[__] up do you I mean how much do you
attribute it to the last name versus
also just being in a neighborhood full
of bullies and your smaller kids like if
your name was Williams are you getting
as much I can tell you that the get hard
thing was actually not the biggest
that's what I'm saying it was not the
biggest thing it was it was
it was being smaller and nerdier being
smart yeah
being uh
I think these kids sense that me and him
probably had a path out
our family was like middle class yeah
like our family started I remember being
very young and I look back now and I go
oh that's when we were working class
oh that's when we were lower middle
class oh we moved a few blocks away
to a neighborhood where it was still the
same neighborhood but now we were over
Harrison Avenue and we got sent to a
better we got to take the bus up the
hill to that okay that's when we were
solidly middle class and I could track
that you know
and some of these kids I like I said I
do feel great empathy for because I go
if you're a kid and your dad drinks too
much and hits you
you're going to want to hit somebody
else
and unfortunately that happened to be
the smaller smarter kids who was maybe
maybe they were sensing
oh these guys are probably gonna go to
college
these guys are probably gonna find a way
out you know um
and that was
at the core of it I think I think that
was at the Corvette they actually made
fun of me for having a giant forehead
they used to call me mega head and it
would piss me off that was my childhood
nickname Mega head and uh
that was a
far more than the get hard thing because
the get hard thing was like what are we
gonna do you know what I mean like what
are we gonna do I think also there was
some
subconscious element looking back on it
of them being like that's his that's
their dad's name too yeah you know
like there was some element of which you
have to defend yourself and there was
some element of
my parents did in a way that I think was
sometimes Justified and maybe sometimes
not more often than not though Justified
of like guys at some point you got to go
back out there you got to solve it
yourselves you got it I mean you know
man unfortunately your name comes with
some you're gonna have to defend
yourself now you said Your son's four my
son's four yeah so he's got the last
name you know it's common at some point
there's gonna be at least maybe not the
way it was back then but kids are dicks
they are there's gonna be a kid or two
or whatever that's gonna get on them as
soon as they learn what getting hard
even is yeah but you're right it's about
middle school when you start figuring
all that stupid [__] out it's gonna be a
[__] problem yeah he already maybe
six months ago I was in the car with him
and he said Daddy what's a bully
and it hit this you can imagine for me
and I was like um you know it's like
it's somebody who likes to pick on other
people and I was like why are you asking
me and he there's another kid in our
neighborhood he goes is blank I'm gonna
say a kid's name you know it's like is
Blanca bully
and I know the kid he's talking about in
our neighborhood and he's a he's a good
his family's a good kid but he is like
I'm like
any time you see kids in an argument or
neighborhood he's at least there you
know what I mean yeah and I got a lot of
love for this kid but he's a shitster I
hear you and he'll grow out of it
because he's from a good family but he
is and I'm like my son is not wrong I'm
like yeah
I think that kid is I was like you're
pretty smart Cal because I think that
you like you're wondering what a bully
is and you're he and yeah you're right
he is and I go why do you ask
and he told me
long story where the kid said some some
harsh stuff to a kid younger than him
closer to my son's this kid's probably
five or six years older than my son
and uh he got mad at one of the little
kids in the neighborhood and said some
real some mean stuff to try to scare the
kid and I pulled the car over and I was
like cow
if he ever said anything like that to
you
you can tell me
I was like if you need to say something
mean back to him you can
and I was like and if if you ever if he
ever pushes you
or whoever makes you feel unsafe
and you have to hit him
I was like I don't know if you'll
understand this yet
you're gonna have to get in trouble for
it but I'm never gonna be mad at you the
same thing I told my daughter the same
yeah don't you hit first yeah you have
to defend yourself you can hit teachers
said we can't I said I'll I'll have a
conversation with the teacher you let me
get in trouble with the teacher like I
might take you out for ice cream yeah
we're gonna you might have a harsh
Conversation Over Ice Cream like that's
right you know like because there's
something also to be said for that of
like your last name spells get hard you
are gonna take some [__] along the way
now look I hope I don't have to threaten
to kill kids with a pipe
you know but I'll tell you what
a lot of those things that my dad did
back then
I know I looked back and I would laugh
at those stories I'd be like man my dad
could go crazy now that I have a kid I'm
like he wasn't crazy at all he was like
pissed and felt packed into a corner and
his family too family yeah and when like
calling the other parents and it's not
changing calling the school we started
we all talk about the kids I all grew up
with dude to this day we all are like
man
I don't think this stuff was even
getting written down because I think
that's cool I think it was all a
property value game I think a lot of us
are like the worst
the more the reputation got out that
that school was bad the more that it
would have affected how sale prices in
that neighborhood and they weren't going
to let that happen I don't think that
stuff was even getting run up the chain
I think there were incident reports that
they weren't even they probably weren't
even clicking the pen when the parents
reporting it they weren't even writing
it down a lot of that stuff got swept
under the rug
and uh
my son's not growing up in a place like
that so I hope it will be better though
he will have to deal with it
um and I'm hoping I can teach him how to
handle it in a way that's like you need
to know where the boundaries are and
when they are crossed you need to know
when it's time to act you need to
understand that there will be
consequences
that when you do have to act on them
it gonna there you might have to get
suspended or you might have to get
yelled at a little bit but
if you ever sit it down sit me down and
explain to me here's why what happened
happened and I sit here and I go
you needed to defend yourself because
sometimes in life nobody else is
defending you like
you're not I'm not gonna be mad
I didn't tell him I'd be proud
there might be some elements of that
along the way but at the very least I'm
not going to be mad at them I I saw too
much along the way yeah you know buying
tickets to your favorite event shouldn't
be stressful you ever try to get good
tickets somewhere and you're like oh I
got this seat but you got to sit behind
me it happened to me one time we got two
seats together one in front one behind
it's ridiculous I don't like it game
time is the fast and easy way to buy
tickets for all the sports music comedy
and theater near you with killer deals
on last minute tickets and their best
price guarantee you can stop stressing
over the tickets and start getting
excited for the fun you'll have the game
time app makes it insanely easy to buy
tickets for any event in your area once
you open the app you can sort by popular
events in your area buy event types
sport music or shows or by venue it is
the fastest growing ticketing app in the
country for a reason get images of your
seat before you buy so you know exactly
what to expect when you arrive I know
you guys want to know if I use this
stuff I 100 did uh Orioles are coming to
play the angels in September I use the
game time app I checked my seats on the
first base side behind the visit are dug
out got some really good seats at a
really good price and I'm taking my
daughter to her first ever professional
sports game going to see the Orioles all
right you buy tickets in a matter of
seconds two TAPS in your set tickets are
sent directly to your phone so you never
have to dig through your email all right
snag the tickets without the stress with
Game Time download the game time app
create an account use code honeydew for
twenty dollars off your first purchase
terms apply again create an account and
redeem code honeydew for twenty dollars
off download game time today last minute
tickets lowest price guaranteed our next
partner is athletic greens I heard about
athletic greens and decided to give them
a try because my energy and my immune
system could both use a little boost
it's become part of my morning routine
which means I'm starting every day
feeling like I'm doing something great
for my body more than just greens it's
all your key Health Products like
multivitamins minerals pre and
probiotics and more working together as
one it's made with 75 high quality
quality vitamins minerals and Whole Food
sourced ingredients that deliver
benefits like mood immune system and
sleep support sustained energy and so
much more you can even get it in
convenient travel packs for when you're
on the go like I'm using on the upcoming
tour live and Alive go get your tickets
at ryancicler.com so if you want to take
ownership of your health today is a good
time to start athletic greens is giving
you a free one-year supply of vitamin D
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase go to athletic greens.com
honeydew that's athletic greens.com
honeydew check it out this podcast is
sponsored by betterhelp it is so easy to
get caught up in what everyone else
needs from you and never take a moment
to think about what you need from
yourself I know for me right now I need
to get my health squared away that's the
most important I'm working on promoting
a special we're uh doing two shows a
tour it's a lot but when we spend all of
our time giving it can leave us feeling
stretched thin and burned out therapy
can give you the tools to find more
balance in your life so you can keep
supporting others without leaving
yourself behind better help connect you
with a licensed therapist who can take
you on that journey of self-discovery
from wherever you are if you're thinking
of giving therapy a try better help is a
great option it's convenient flexible
affordable and entirely online just fill
out a brief questionnaire to get matched
with a licensed therapist and you can
always switch the therapist anytime for
no additional charge if you want to live
a more empowered life therapy can get
you there visit betterhelp.com honeydew
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
betterhelp.com
honeydew now let's get back to the do
well let's flip the script because your
mom took the last name obviously right
that she did my wife has not very
smartly my wife's last name is bullet
like the bourbon dude it was the
quickest conversation ever she's like uh
from bullet to get
you think I should take your name
you have the cool
it like the bourbon of spells like the
bourbon hi I'm Chris gethard you know
like you're not signing up for that I
tried to convince her to let our son
have a hyphenated name she wouldn't do
it she was like I don't know I'm like
then he can use your name in school
she was like I don't think so she's like
she feels a little she's like maybe I
should have taken your name or
partnership I'm like I don't care and
like I don't I don't really believe in
it some old archaic [__] that's when
you used to sell women for sheep you
know what I mean like they're getting
some cattle here but I was like let's
get it on his birth certificate and then
he can use that name in school who cares
she's like I feel weird about it but
what about your mom did she encounter
any of that she took the name I mean my
mom is quietly one of the funniest
people I've ever met so I think she
always was able to laugh you know she
was always able to make a comment under
her breath and my brother and I learned
that too that was another defense
mechanism I think I learned my father's
if you push me too far
you're gonna like with me I was small my
dad only had to set the example once he
was big for me I think I had a
reputation of like
you can [__] with that kid
but amongst the small kids he's gonna
make it it's a Tasmanian and like you're
probably gonna win the fight but guess
what like it's gonna be a fight you're
gonna be surprised you're not leaving
the same time
yeah like you're gonna win but like he's
gonna be bleeding more but you're gonna
be bleeding a little bit too you know
like that was my reputation like that
and I also used to have a thing it was
so I think I think back dude and it was
so warped whenever I would get in a
fight as a kid
I would get so emotionally worked up
that I'd start crying yeah that
adrenaline you know adrenaline process
it yeah I remember getting fights with
kids and and I'd be like and I feel the
story when he just heard and I feel the
tears coming down my face and I remember
a few distinct times where that happened
where the bullies
see in their face that they were like
what the [__] what the [__] is going and
then and it was the last fight with that
bully because they were like this is
weird there was one one in middle school
that I pulled off that kind of stopped a
lot of the bullying for me there's one
kid who kept uh
he lived in my neighborhood and we'd
walk to middle school and he'd he'd walk
on the other side of the street and I
remember he always used to pretend he
was pushing up his glasses because I
always used you know I was that kid
where like you're in Middle School
classes are in your book bag they get
bent and I'd always be pushing up my
glasses and he'd stand across the street
and be like hey get hard you're really
cool man you're and he pretended he was
pushing up his glasses and it went on
for a couple days
and I was like what's the deal John
and I tried to ignore it
and uh he was like he's like one of
these little like
spine he was not big he was like he was
a [__] talker to try to show off you
know
and then I noticed oh now he's got a guy
with him from the neighborhood because
he said check this out and now it's two
of them across the street and then it's
three and I'm like
I gotta stop it you know I could feel it
I gotta stop it
and I was starting to get scared and
then uh he was a year older than me and
then we were walking home one day and we
used to like I said you would walk past
this chain link fence and then you were
off school property and you generally
cut across this church parking lot and
all the fights would happen there
because the teachers wouldn't stop it
and like but like I said if you looked
out the window they were watching they
could see the fights
it was a chain link fence to see through
right you could spit through to them so
I mean here's the Gap in the fence you
step through it fights there after
school all the time
and this kid was following me and he's
behind me and now there's like three
kids with him and I got like my three
buddies with me and we're all like we're
sixth graders he's they're seventh
graders he's behind me going you're so
cool getting hard you're so cool
and uh
and uh I could hear the other seventh
grade kids laughing I was like I gotta
stop it and I took my book bag off and
put it on the ground and my back was to
him he's like what are you gonna do man
and I turned around and I was just
crying and I saw in his face he was like
and I was like
and the tears were coming because I once
I knew I was gonna get in a fight it
because I want to be clear with all
these stories there's not one percent of
me that thinks this is cool you're
scared as [__] I used to tell some of
these stories in my 20s or I'd be on
stage when I was coming up in comedy 27
20 be like I used to actually I know I'm
nerdy but I used to get in [__]
fights but I'm past the point of
pretending that I ever thought there was
anything interesting or commendable
about having to do this it's twisted I
wish none of this happened but I'm like
and I saw in the kid's face he was just
like oh no no and I didn't say a thing
and I walked up
and I can tell you honestly it was the
best punch I've ever landed on a human I
put hit I put it on his chin now he hit
the floor that's lights out on the chin
the other seventh graders were like
and then it was just a crowd because
people used to go to that parking lot to
see the fight and everybody was like
like you know one of those kid fights
where there's no adults around and
there's kids like actually dancing enjoy
it like the little kid yeah the little
sixth grade kid put him on his [__]
ass and I turned around and I walked
away and then he came after me the next
day and he found me a little bit further
away and he got me down on the ground
and he was kicking me kicking me and I
was trying to block him and an adult
came out of a house and broke it up damn
and he never said another word to me
after that he tried to get his receipt
and then got out of there and even that
one I would argue was a bit of a draw he
got me down but he was trying to kick at
me and I was trying to find my way back
up and an adult came and was like whoa
oh God is it this is [__] up guys walk
different threats you know when it's an
adult nobody knows yeah everybody
scatters yeah and that was like uh
I got one fight in high school and it
was a similar thing of some kid from the
other side of town who didn't know my
reputation threw something at me in the
lunchroom and I turned around and took a
like one of those you know remember they
used to sell like the iced tea and the
we had like an ice an orange drink they
sold in like a milk carton it was like
50 cents back in the day and I just took
a full one and they had been throwing
some food at my friends these kids and
uh
finally it hit me and I just picked it
up and turned around and was like Bond
through this full milk carton into the
and he was big
I remember as he stood up I was a
freshman he was a sophomore junior as he
stood up I was like oh he's it just
keeps going
he's like six one
I didn't hit puberty until junior year
high school I'm like oh my God
I remember like he's got Orange
I remember trying to like grab his
clothes and hold him down as he was
getting up to try to get some shots
I'm like it's going past my eyeline
um
dude I remember like thinking like
someone break this up someone break this
upside and like the teachers finally got
there and I was like oh thank God oh
thank God and that was the last fight I
got into in school
it's the last fight I ever got into in
school yeah
and when that was it after that no I got
one fight at a concert at a Weezer
concert of all places but that was just
some idiot he was just completely
idiotic drunk Jersey Shore kid just some
Jersey Shore [__] mooc who uh he was
cross-eyed drunk and tried to fight me
and he
he like bumped into me so I sort of like
brushed him away not aggressive and then
all of a sudden he turned around I saw
him I was like what he's coming and he
swung at me and he missed and he hit a
girl oh and the girl's boyfriend
obviously jumped in and we just threw
him on the ground and security got there
that was the last actual that was
probably like 22 in that 21 when that
happened um
so that was an outlier
but as far as having to feel like I had
to kind of fight
to
survive
which I guess is a melodramatic way to
put it but they're it's at the very
least accurate to how I felt back then
um and this is not just me
it's very sad for me to realize every
time I catch up with people I grew up
with it's like we just even on the days
where there weren't fights we walked
around as kids scared that it was about
to happen yeah and it's not a good way
to grow up you know
um and it went on for
years
and uh
yeah it definitely affected my
personality to this day it did yeah oh
I've had to unwrap so much of it so much
of it
uh but yeah that's
that's a lot of the low lights of the
childhood I haven't thought about the
time they forced us to fight that's been
a long time yeah that really is that's
probably the low light we probably got
to the low light on that one yeah yeah
fight your brother for our reviews
my dude my brother though it was crazy
because he never wanted to listen no
offense if it's a draw I gotta give you
the W you're three years younger and
smaller but we also were just looking
for our way out yeah of course yeah but
I mean dude this guy I was much more of
a fighter than he was but I've always
told him I'm like it's nuts that you
weren't a fighter because he he was like
a real nerdy guy
like I was nerdy he also had braces and
stuff like like there was this we're all
at our worst yeah yeah but he also I was
like it's crazy you weren't a fighter
because
I knew he and I would fight sometimes
and there's been a couple times where he
hit me and like put me on my ass I'm
like you got a straight right
that you know they say like you're born
with the ability to punch or you're born
with the ability to throw a baseball
like those are two things that they say
like you're just kind of born with it in
you I'm like because you had a punch
he's like I know
this wasn't I just didn't want it I look
back I go man it bums me out
but there's also something kind of
beautiful about it because he was like I
didn't want to participate in that as
like the Baseline yeah just because it
can doesn't mean I want to like this
shouldn't be happening whereas I I have
a lot of regret because I did opt into
it why do you regret that
why can't they both be independently
true of one another your brothers is
very interesting thought you know it
brings to mind like I was so I did the
Jersey thing I went to public school and
then I went to Rutgers University the
state school
and you know mo a lot of places this is
state school it's like a third of your
graduating class winds up at Rutgers in
New Jersey especially we came from like
a
like
not great High School not awful High
School
everybody winds up at Rutgers you know
and I wound up
two years of college living with a buddy
who I went from kindergarten through
Rutgers with bam grew up a couple blocks
away from me we walked to school he was
there a lot of the stories I've told you
this was a kid who was present for him
my buddy Butch
and we had this moment I'll never forget
a Butch anymore no it was his last name
that was his last name yeah but yeah of
course you're gonna you don't need a
butcher anymore no no no but I remember
you know you'd be sitting around in the
dorm in the lounge and there's all these
kids from different towns and pretty
much everybody's from New Jersey
everybody's telling stories trying to
make each other laugh and this person
tells a story about this crazy thing
that happened in their High School
and then this person who grew up in
South Jersey tells a story about oh
here's the senior prank day and what we
did and then me or Butch would be like
ah we got one and we'd tell one of our
stories from West Orange and everybody
would just go [__] silent every time
and we'd be sitting at each other and
they'd be like that's not funny and like
I'd be telling a story and Butch would
be laughing like you just did he'd be
like
or he'd be telling a story and I'd be
like ah yeah I was there I was there for
that part like the other part I can't he
might be excited that [__] I saw and
people would be looking at us like what
the [__] are you two talking about and I
remember one night he and I were back in
our room after one of those days
and I remember him just being like
dude
we just kind of assumed that's what high
school was like and Junior High School
we just we thought everybody at every
High School
was dealing with this [__] yeah people
fighting in a church parking lot
teachers telling you it's off school
property so go deal with it on your own
we won't help
you know the we thought everybody had
the kids where they went their parents
were abusive so they got a pass to just
behave like maniacs sometimes and then
you I remember us being in our room and
him just being like
dude it didn't
it didn't have to be like that it wasn't
like that for the rest of these people
we're coming off like psychos
it wasn't like that and I remember he
and I both
got pretty
mad
and I tell you I I I I dealt with a lot
of I I've always dealt with a lot of
mental illness stuff
are you talking about personally or in
your family personally I mean both but
personally
and uh
it's a chi I I think back it's a chicken
and an egg thing like was I really
depressed because of this stuff was this
stuff exasperating this existing thing
and making it worse but I actually think
back to it and I go my freshman year of
college when Butch and I realized that
that was when the depression for the
first time got really really out of
control really yeah in what way because
I I can verbalize this now back then I
wouldn't have been able to verbalize it
but to realize like there's this like I
have all this anger
and I have a lot of fear
we grew up like that
and then you get to cut like to this day
I'm still somebody like
you know
my wife will be like I'm just running
into the store let's not lock the doors
I'm like no you lock the [__] doors
like I'm just someone who's just like
assumed the worst is gonna happen yeah
you know assume the worst is gonna
happen always
and you can imagine how pronounced it
was when I'm out 18 19 years old at
College living on my own for the first
time not in that town and
I think because a lot of the kids in the
neighborhood also had parents who grew
up there and grandparents who still
lived there like I could see into my
grandfather's backyard from my bedroom
window okay my dad's sister lived right
around the block my other grandparents
lived three blocks away my mom's sister
lived two blocks away
but what starts to happen
is
you grew up that way your parents grew
up that way your grandparents raised
them that way so this is normal and then
you get to a town that maybe wasn't that
tight-knit with all these very
idiosyncratic things
and you realize oh it wasn't normal
and that realization of like
I have this
cynicism
feeling that people have bad intentions
this feeling that you better get your
own back because nobody else is going to
get your back
the you know these feelings that
you got to be able to you got to be
ready to cut and run from situations
because if it starts to get wild
you might need to just get out of a
situation
those were things that were so inherent
to me
and to realize that
that wasn't just
how it was
that it could have been different
that those [__] teachers could have
been
doing more protectors yeah yeah
hmm
it filled me with like so much
regret
and anger
and it really flared up bad and then the
depression really set in you know yeah I
remember
um you know
there were times where and I remember a
specific thing with my brother where
my parent my mom went to the school to
pick him up because
bad stuff had happened and he actually
had a bone broken he had his broken
shoulder for the thing that happened in
school
and um
my mom was like okay just you know not
the first thing that's happened but this
is
I'm gonna have to take the kid to the
hospital yeah she goes so what's gonna
happen to the kid
and they go well you know his uh family
life is really bad
and we have been made aware that their
father is physically abusive with this
family this family had a lot of kids
like we've been made aware it's
physically abusive so
uh with this family
um we've learned that we can't suspend
or expel the kids because it's leading
to physical abuse in their home because
they go home they're stuck and their dad
and my mom's going
that's awful
I feel so bad for that kid but my son
has a broken bone
and like you think of that
and then to get to college and realize
like
oh not not everybody else had [__] like
that swept under the road no not like I
think back now as an adult and a father
and I'm like all right
suspend that kid and call in in Jersey
it was dyphus the Division of Youth and
Family Services get those kids out of
that house with that Dad you weren't
helping us you weren't helping my
brother you weren't helping [__] dad
out you weren't you get them arrested
right you weren't helping anybody you
weren't helping that family by just
throwing your hand under the rug yeah
okay like we don't want to exacerbate
the abuse at home I agree
so you're basically just turning a blind
eye to it instead
and we're living in this
consequence-free environment when
there's actual and now I'm also old
enough and smart enough to know
that kid who's 12 13 years old doing
that
that's a cry for help from the kid
the kid doesn't want to get away with
breaking somebody else's bone the kid's
living if you're a 12 year old kid
fighting to the point where a bone gets
you're living in a horror show in your
own head you know so [__] like that
I just look back on I'm like it's
unforgivable it's unforgivable and I
have this very layered
relationship with my old neighborhood
where I'm like I
still
am like
I don't care anything I've done
in entertainment
anything that anything that seems fancy
I'm like at the end of the day I'm like
like I think of myself as like a down
the hill kid I'm like down the hill
and that's like a piece of my identity
too but I also have so much actual like
hatred
of what that meant 30 years ago you know
is there anything
positive that's come out of this
negative that you actually do appreciate
I mean or maybe it's made you someone
that you might not have been had you not
been I'm glad you asked because I can
say a million like
I look back now and I'm like man
almost all of the failings of my
hometown and my childhood experience
come down to teachers and administrators
and that [__] where they were
looking the other way because actually
so many kids I grew up with are like
when I tell you like I just recently
found my junior high school yearbook
I'm going through it and I'm like about
a third of the class is black
there's Asian kids Hispanic kids
probably like 65 white kids I'm like I
grew up with everybody
and I also want to be clear too I hope
it's been made clear in case anyone
wants to read between the lines I think
I've said a million times the kids who
had who gave it to me hardest do I still
resent the most were other Irish
Catholic kids mostly the Catholic school
kids the public school kids I'm like
I've talked to other people I grew up
with but I'm like man like people have
this dream of diversity being a good
thing today and we had that in the 90s
in high school in a middle school and
high school in New Jersey when I got to
my high school they told us
there were 40 different languages spoken
amongst the student body I got there in
1995. you know people today would be
trying to like move to a school system
to have their kids raised around that
grew up with everybody and I think a lot
of people
[Music]
who I grew up with will agree like
put us in a room
with people who look different than us
grew up a different way than us
different background we'll fight we'll
figure out a way to talk to each other
because we all figured that out and that
that is a thing that I look back on and
I'm like I mean learning how to fight
for myself I think absolutely helped a
career in entertainment you know yeah
figuring out how to take a knock and get
back up and yeah yes absolutely figuring
out down get up and also not and let
some [__] roll off you too like that
what you're saying to me right now isn't
is nothing compared to what I've dealt
with in life letting stuff roll off you
for sure but then also the other thing
too of like
having your ego [__] with
and still knowing how to finish the day
even when it's not rolling off you yeah
just like man I got [__] embarrassed
right there but there's three hours left
in the day and I better put my game face
back on and get through it even though
it's gonna be sitting inside I'm gonna
be pissed all day you know
um learning how to have both those
things coexist is really good in
entertainment I'm like hey here's
something that makes you feel awful or
something that makes you feel
pissed or make you question yourself but
also you can still function while that's
happening that's a skill yeah so I've
learned some of that but I think
that's the I think back to it I go man
growing up in the environment I did
where there's so many different people
you know
black kids white kids Hispanic kids
Catholic kids Jewish kids everybody all
mixing together I'm like man
that in many ways was a real source of
strength that a lot of us when we see
each other still like this is [__]
cool
and imagine how much even better it
could have been
if those teachers
and administrators
we're doing things the right way like it
could have been it could have been like
a success Factory that school system
but they were worried about the wrong
things you know
but even in spite of that I think a lot
of us grew up where it's like
you know
certain parts of North Jersey are like
that because it's so dense
it's like you put in North even me I'm
like an introverted guy but you put me
in an environment and I'm generally
going to figure out I had a friend of
mine recently um I tour with the
beautiful Anonymous podcast and my
producer towards with me comes on the
road to record them and she's like
there's a very weird thing about you
where she's like I've now spent enough
time on the road with you car rides
plane rides sitting in airport terminals
eating at restaurants doing the shows
she's like you are undoubtedly an
introvert I see it
I've also never met someone who can get
into a conversation with an Uber driver
quicker than you can
feel the same I'll small fault the [__]
out of everybody but I do feel it hard
I'm an intro and I feel like I'm an
extroverted introvert if that makes any
I know I get up in front of hundreds
thousands of people whatever and do this
thing but I also don't I also just want
to go the [__] home and be by myself
absolutely and I've said I thought about
it after she said it I was like that's
funny but I'm like first of all you grow
up in the most densely populated state
your people are everyone's around each
other all the time and I think also just
growing up the way I did I quickly
learned like all right I'm in a room
with you let's figure out something we
have in common let's figure out
something to talk about oh that I'm
smart I have a question about that oh
you grew up where oh I actually went
you're in that country I've never been
there but I've been in the country next
door to it it was beautiful you know
like
and I think some of that has served me
really well and some of that was
probably born as a defense mechanism
when I was young of like I gotta find
the common ground with everybody really
quick because when you grow up scared
you better walk into a room and be like
okay there's six of you guys and you're
starting to laugh
well if one of if I've made one of you
laugh or if I realized that
if we've had a conversation about how
your mom and my mom
went to elementary school together or
we've had a conversation about how like
oh you actually grew up in Newark oh my
dad went to high school and work a few
blocks from there now I've been
humanized so maybe out of that group of
six that's laughing when I walk in the
room there's one of them that goes he's
cool guys you know and that I learned
that young I learned that young and that
has served me well and you know now that
it's in a context where it's not about
safety it can be used pretty well in a
room where
you walk into a comedy club and there's
a whole bunch of comedians that know
each other and you don't know each other
I can generally sit down
and figure a way in you know I'm on the
road and there's a venue and maybe
things aren't set up the right way and
that sound isn't working and we got okay
I can figure out a way to make a joke
where this isn't going to be tense we're
all just going to get through it you
know and a lot of that was the defense
mechanisms of my youth so let me ask you
this then after talking about everything
we've talked about I asked my first time
guest advice they would give to their 16
year old self so I am actually very
curious because this is throwing that
pocket of high school for you so what
advice would you give 16 year old Chris
there's a couple things I would say
which is uh
one that directly applies to all this
and it's a piece of advice that was
given to me
and I am bummed because I don't remember
who said this to me but one of the big
things that helped me unwrap a lot of
stuff was I remember someone when I was
like college post College
and I was still very much like on guard
and had that thing of
like oh you want to be my friend prove
to me why I should allow him you know um
and I had somebody say to me like you
know man like
people will surprise you all the time
but you gotta let them
and that
changed a lot of things for me so I
would pass that advice on because if I
got that when I was 16 it made it's made
so much inherent sense to me that it
would have made sense at 16 and it would
have diffused a lot of the tension of
just like
people most people aren't bad most
people are
good to neutral and most people want to
find a reason to laugh with you or have
something in common with you allow that
in life will be easier and that helped
and then another one which is has you
know
absolutely nothing to do with what we've
talked about I would tell my 16 year old
self like hey in two years you're gonna
go to Rutgers
don't fall in love with that girl who
lives on your floor freshman year it's
gonna he's gonna [__] up your whole
college experience
but you and her are going to remain
lifelong friends keep it friendly
because when you dabbled with romance
holy [__] did it [__] with both your
heads don't fall in love with her don't
fall in love with you y'all you'll
you'll be able to have a lot more fun in
college if you're not worried about that
one girl you met freshman year go have
more fun in college let your guard down
hell yeah thank you very much thank you
we got we got dark we got intense I
guess I should have expected it but it
went to some places I didn't expect will
you please promote everything again as
well one more time sure yeah if people
like you know honest conversations and
feel like I have shown you that I can
navigate one of the beautiful Anonymous
podcasts go subscribe today Chris
geth.com to keep tabs on my ticket sales
and you know Chris Geth on Instagram
Chris gethard on Twitter those are all
the usual places all right thank you
very much again thank you dude uh as
always Ryan sickler on all social media
Ryan sickler.com go watch the special
come see me on tour we'll talk to y'all
next week
[Music]
foreign